Hoda Kotb breaking down in tears on the
Today Show The Morning Show co-anchor is
still working from the NBC studio in New
York City while most of her co-workers
filmed the show from their homes
amid the corona virus outbreak and on
Friday Hoda got emotional after
finishing her interview with NFL Pro
Drew Brees who donated five million
dollars to Louisiana coronavirus relief
of course Brees is the longtime
quarterback for the New Orleans Saints
Hoda who used to live in the Big Easy is
a huge fan I think you're right I also
think a lot of things are contagious
including generosity so our hope is is
that because you know you let us know
that you made this big generous donation
I think other people look and say hey
maybe I can help out too
Jota did her best to fight back tears
that's what ho does co-anchor Savannah
Guthrie who is currently filming the
show from home attempted to comfort Hoda
live on the air it's a lot I know where
your heart is my dear I do how about I
read the tease just okay
okay deep breaths Hoda was able to
continue with the broadcast after the
commercial break
especially to rejoice in some good news
the Today family all came together to
celebrate the birth of fellow co-host
Carson Daly's fourth child Goldie
they're very excited little gogo as
we're gonna call Goldie later in the
show Hoda and Savannah opened up about
her emotional moment you sort of look
around for someone to hug just because
and you realize okay yeah that's that's
also part of it but anyway the new
normal if we get used to it right yes
and it's not forever
yes I'm gonna be awkwardly hugging you
you're gonna be like get off me Savannah
you're a creep get out of here and I'm
not gonna stop hugging you up it's been
a
tough month for the morning show MVC
staffer Larry Edgeworth died last week
after testing positive for corona virus
Hoda and Savannah remembered Larry and a
touching tribute on The Today Show
earlier this week and I remember
thinking like wow what a guy in a world
where people are constantly talking
about how they're doing and how they're
feeling he's always asking how everyone
was doing and feeling and he did he made
you feel safe